these are my two traveling companions
when i don't have my babies with me
which i normally do but if i don't
these go everywhere with me
[Music]
well they're all essential to me because
they're essentials but here we go first
essential if i'm walking out the house
no matter what i gotta have water so
i make it montana
i dislike plastic very much so i got a
water bottle i got my modern olive
that's number one aquaman needs water
all right next essential healthcare i
mean you know like uh
just the essentials you know i mean i
used to carry my bag
toothbrush
spork
i dig these things man so shampoo bar so
i just use that for it's just a bar so i
don't use plastic lip balm
bite so it's toothpaste and then this
really good uh i like this deodorant by
it's called uh palo santo and
frankincense but it's by humble the only
problem is it's in plastic so i'm gonna
do my best to kind of call donovan up
and change this
so i wanna make it so i can have
everything plastic free which is my goal
now that i've become aquaman it's
there's just a lot of things i wanna do
to try to save yourself i think there
was a moment where i was sitting on a
plane
and uh you know there's a can of beer
there's a can of soda water there's a
can of coke and then there's this
goddamn little bottle of water that's
like a shot of water with
two three different types of plastic on
it the wrap or the top and i was just
like this is insane so that's why i
started to make money
so you make canned water you know it's
infinitely recyclable and i just i was
like why aren't we doing this and i just
think drinking out of plastic bottles is
disgusting so and it's not good for you
it's not good for the earth you know
when you travel as much as i do it's
just like there's that single-use
plastic everywhere and i just get tired
of it and so i wanted to not [ __ ] about
it i wanted to do stuff about it next
essential is gotta be music so i i mean
this is kind of the only thing i
i know [ __ ] travel with
tons of records i probably travel with
at least 300 to 400 records that are
just like essentials so i just brought
out a record you know this is just on
record day this is a sabbath so i always
i love vinyl and i travel with record
players so i have a record player that's
in my trailer when we get ready in the
morning there's one normally in the gym
i love that and then i kind of travel
everywhere with these because the
marshalls it's just you know if i do
want to hook up to my phone um this is
perfect for me it's like being a
vagabond and you know traveling
everywhere it's like i can be in the
dirt and you know anywhere i want to be
climbing and i can just haul this thing
around with me it's like this huge thing
and then um yeah it's just obviously
rock and roll which leads me to my
absolute next i'm a big fan of playing
guitar and slide blues and then i
started learning bass too i mean i kind
of travel with a lot of instruments
not only for myself but also for my
children so you know they can play a lot
like there's a piano right there like my
daughter's been playing piano she's a
trumpet they both did violin i started
getting into bass when my son was
getting heavy into drums so we travel
with the drum set probably bring about
12 guitars with me
i don't rock and roll it all night baby
my next uh essential is the wallet i
made i can put my phone in there some
cash and cards so it's got everything i
need in there i made this wallet with uh
on aquaman too so it's just something
that was made with a couple different
artists it's got some carvings in there
it's got you know my tattoo and
different things so this is just my
chain wallet i i make a lot of different
chain wallets so
my phone fits in there so obviously this
is about essential as it gets stay in
touch with my family
photos we picked out this is the shark
skin and then this is from a bull rings
that you know used for bulls this is
what i wore in aquaman and this is what
you know wearing
aquaman to i didn't sell this one
together i have many of them that i have
made this one right here we had to make
like four or five of them so production
made it on aquaman one but
this is all the stuff that i picked and
designed and all that kind of stuff this
is like a coin that was hand carved by a
friend i
absolutely love photography my friend
made these little cases for me for on
their own pretty neat but this is my um
it's my m2 i generally have an m2 and m3
it's a film camera it's a 50 millimeter
lens yeah it's just a beautiful
workhorse i love lycos and i love you
know the shoot film at but the same time
i love shooting digital too i just fell
in love with this camera so m10p it's
shooting through like 19 you know 30s
and 40s glass but using digital so my
whole idea was like be able to take
something that's so crisp and clear with
digital but be able to shoot through old
glass i enjoy like experimenting with
that kind of stuff
damien do you have the red here so this
thing's 6k
it's in the palm of your hand it's
insane it's the red komodo and they made
me a brass one i was annoyed by my
mother at a very early age she would
pull over constantly we'd be driving
trying to get somewhere she'd pull over
need to take a picture and pull
everybody to take a picture until i
realized
you know when i saw my mother's pictures
and i could see her eye and see how she
captured things and see how she saw the
world after i got into acting then i
really you know it just kind of linked
up with cinematography so i uh
i started shooting my next essential is
extremely important it's
all about
potato
and
piggy big spirit so this is my baby girl
lola and this is wolf and listen if you
have babies you know you got stuffed
animals and if you're not with your
babies then you're gonna be cuddling
stuffed animals i think it's a little
too personal so unfortunately i won't
get into the stories because that's just
for me and my family but this is for
lola this is picky big spirit and this
is uh potato which is hilarious because
wolfie just
got this amazing character and they
called it potato and i thought that was
the most genius name for uh
for stuffed animal so they sleep in bed
with me yeah
my little babies are in bed with me
right now they're actually watching a
movie right now but it's it's yeah i
travel
gotta have pig and potato next item this
is kind of goes in in hand with uh what
i was telling you about this is a belt
that my buddy made tabernacle we made
these knucklehead so it's for my
favorite bike so i love bikes obviously
that's one of my essentials it's not
here right now
so you can chalk that up to eight i
travel with many motorcycles
but this is the knucklehead so it's like
kind of my it's a harley davidson and um
and then knives you know i really love
knives i travel a lot of knives a lot of
my friends make them
buddy my chris made this into panga so
it's a local artisan i love supporting
local
gotta have a knife with me so
that's one of mine and just the whole
idea of just making handcrafted artists
really exciting to me my number eight
essential is harley-davidson bikes i
love them they're my favorite greatest
bikes in the world
my favorite so that was kind of my
example to go i love harley i've always
wanted a motorcycle whole life and i
think i mean i made a piece about it you
can kind of watch it it's called where
the wild stomped in so you can like go
see it on youtube that's the one that we
make it's about my first bike and then i
made one for me and my children
ultimately i just i love
i love riding motorcycles and i love
riding around you know the world on them
all right this is kind of weird but
but it's mine so my next essential is uh
my carhartt pants
[Music]
my dirty ass carhartt pants i traveled
the world with them they got my war
stories they've been through everything
with me and uh
they're my favorite they're the most
durable i love them yeah number nine is
it's literally my cards
i mean i've had these pants since high
school
so
they're it's a it's a long time another
thing i made a a little spot about
called
it's called canvas of my life
and it's uh it's about these pants so
please do check it out you've been with
me forever they've been through every up
and down man i'm hawaiian so i gotta
have my sleeper i gotta have my
flip-flops
and i gotta have sunglasses
mandatory these are pretty rad i started
making them
and i love them because i just it's it's
so simple we're making them so it's
algae bloom
so my goal is that you can just take
these things and just plant them in your
garden
and you're not going to have all that
waste going into the oceans and going
into the landfills and so my goal is to
like literally make a biodegradable
flip-flop i'm pretty excited about that
so my
company's so ill makes these they're
pink and black my favorite colors
and
i gotta have flip flops two
sunglasses
as many as possible
i think i have a massive collection of
sunglasses and these ones i'm actually
uh making right now with uh electric
they this really cool company they're
doing it all recycled so it's all um you
know
environmentally conscious yeah i'm doing
my own little collab with them and then
they've i've been wearing them forever
because my buddies are surfers with them
so
um a couple motorcycle friends are
sponsored by them couple uh surfer
buddies of mine are friends and they
usually just hook me up and i love them
so i was warm and then eventually we're
like hey let's do something and so now
i got my own line coming out and i'm
pretty stoked about it but gotta have
sunglasses that's it bro that's the 10.
thank you gq i hope you guys enjoyed
that was my 10 essentials and uh please
on august 20th one of my favorite movies
that i've ever done with my best friend
and all my buddies
sweet girls coming out on netflix um i
hope you love it we worked our butt off
and um
and also if you can
me stop single use plastic i love you
hello thank you